- Welcome back.
So throughout the season
I shared a lot of
personal stories of my own
and so I'm very thrilled
to have my own friend
Todd here tonight
because he wants to
share one of his.
Todd, can you tell us your
experience about coming out?
- No.
First off all, let me
say out of paranoia
that I don't want it
to be like my identity
but you know this show you talk
a lot about sexuality a lot
so I guess it comes up.
- Yeah.
- But the person
I'm with now is very
he is like how I was
fifteen years ago
so I don't mention his name or
anything but he's really cool
and he's got a cool
beard and he's great.
(audience laughter)
- You can tell them.
Tell, okay say it to me.
- But, that was locked and
loaded for about an hour.
You know, long story very short
I had a small group
of friends that knew,
all my comedian friends knew,
but then not to get too serious
but there were, there was like
a, it was always happening
but in the news a
lot because there
were a lot of younger kids
you know killing themselves.
- Yeah.
And I thought that if I
don't be honest about this
then it gives validity to
something worth hiding.
- Right.
- So I was like, just about
two years ago, you know let me
just be honest about
it and just come
and life is just
so much better now
life was good before but
its so much better now
its so much better
now. You know?
- Yeah.
(applause)
- Do you feel like people
treat you differently now
that they know you are
an opening gay man?
- Watch your mouth.
You know, the only
one thing is that
people will be
like, look at Todd
he's good at having
parties, he's good at design
and once they found out,
that I came out, I do,
I feel like they're like, I
don't get credit for it anymore.
They're like "well of course,
because he's you know gay."
I said it.
That, that's just a given.
- Yes.
- That everybody gay is
just great at parties,
has an eye for design
when it not true.
- Yeah
- Like Nick is straight but
if he, just for the fun of it
said he was gay,
everybody the next day
in the comedy world would
go "I had a feeling."
- Honestly, I had a feeling.
(applause)
- Well, there are just still
a lot of preconceived notions
out there about gay
men so before the show
we asked our audience to
write down some of theirs.
So we are going
to go through them
and Todd, I would
love it if you would
shed some light on these.
- Yeah and watch me sweat
profusely as I do it.
- I love how fired up
you are about these.
Okay, So Todd help us Debunk
the junk.
- Bring them on!
(applause)
- Here we go.
Okay Todd.
Are you ready?
- Yeah.
- Gay men are always ready.
Okay.
- Sorry
- Just kidding.
Okay, gay men go
to the gym a lot.
- Okay, here we go.
First of all, its
going to change
because gay people didn't
traditionally have children
when they hit 40 years old
where most people are 30
would not be going to the
gym because they have kids
they were at the gym more
because they didn't have kids
its not in your
DNA, so fuck that.
- Love that.
That's smart.
- And as you see, people that
are gay now that have kids
you're going to see, maybe
a little less at the gym.
- Gay men all like musicals.
- Well thats a great one and I
called my friend Daniel today
and he's not gay, and I go
"Daniel what is there any t-."
He goes, "Well I
got a gay friend
"and he doesn't like musicals,
you don't like musicals.
"I don't like musicals.
So there you go."
- There we go.
- What about Chicago though?
They all like Chicago, right?
I mean is it true though
that gay guys do like
getting their dicks sucked?
(laughter)
Because that I don't want to
stereotype but I feel like
- Come on bring them
on, bring them on.
- Barbra Streisand.
- What the fuck!
And just two seconds ago,
one of your producers
said fuck is the only word
they have to edit out.
I don't know what else to say.
- Yeah.
- I don't like Barbra Streisand
I'm not saying
she's not talented
although to tell you the truth
every ten years
she comes on TV go
"I'm so afraid to
sing, I'm so afraid."
I go, you know what, don't!
Don't, I don't give a shit!
Oh, oh, no one knows I-
Go on give me, give me one.
- Gay men have a
lot of bathroom sex.
- Okay that is not, that is
the biggest misconception
is gay men versus men.
Its not gay men, its men, If
women would fuck in bathrooms
straight men would
fuck it bathrooms.
Its not the straight men
that are not doing that
its because they can't.
- Okay, they are
constantly trying
to turn straight guys gay.
- First of all that's men again.
That's men again.
Men don't respect sometimes
because they have
to be the aggressor
don't respect boundaries.
So its the same thing
that a straight guy
would hit on a woman even
though she is giving no signs
that she likes him,
that's what its about.
- It's a little
bit like The Sting
where you are Robert Redford
and your trying to con
them into fucking you.
- Exactly.
- Yes.
- He gets it.
- No no, I meant to
go a different way.
I meant to go a different way.
- Okay this is a-, they
know about a secret tailor
that makes their
suits look better?
- That's, that is true.
- Okay. That is true.
- You are right, that is true.
- Alright thank you Todd
thank you for clearing
some stuff up.
That's all the time we have
for Debunking the Junk.
I'd like to thank my friends
Nick Thune and Todd Glass
for being here tonight.
Nick is on tour right now,
check out dates at nickthune.com
Todd will be Sarah
Silverman in June.
We will be right back, you guys.
(upbeat music)